so i see we have a little bit of a
capacity issue um but
i'm going to do something that they
didn't expect and i'm going to ask my
family to come up here stand next to me
while i speak
so donna and lacey and morgan can you
come up here
and then we're going to fix that phone
sorry about that no you're fine this
dice has got me a little screwed up with
all these mics here so
um so rancho high school how about that
guys
rancho
so you're probably wondering why did i
pick rancho high school
because this is where i graduated from
right 1980
uh successfully graduated it was i was
on the verge
it was on the verge but i pulled it out
and as you can see i stand before you as
a successful graduate of rancho high
school so there's some other folks here
in the audience
that were also graduates of rancho high
school and i hope they don't mind if i
point them out so one of them
very close friend of mine is bobby ellis
we didn't graduate the same year
i think he was here when they were still
pouring the mortar for the walls
and then uh one of my best friends scott
killebrew who's right here in the front
here
no not me is 79
and you were 79 at bonanza with did you
go with mark yes
and then scott we became friends
because he used to protect me he kept me
from getting beat up around the corner
here
and uh no i'm just joking and vic vic up
here in the front he's a fellow rancho
grad and joe i don't know if you went to
rancho did you
no well you probably it was probably
good you didn't go so
um but vic right up here in front uh
former deputy chief from north las vegas
he went to rancho and it just shows you
the success
and the dedication we have for our local
community and
us being homegrown is even more
important as we run for the office of
governor
i think it's important for people to
know that uh me standing before you
i've been here a long time and nevada is
very important to me
and the success of the state is very
important to me and hopefully we'll
continue in that vein
and that brings us home to rancho high
school and before i get into
my words there's a young lady over there
against the wall
who owns this place she's the principal
and she was the one you didn't talk to
when you were in school remember
you tried to avoid her but darlene
delgado the principal rancho high school
i think it's important for we us to
recognize her because of that uh
that effort in the community and i mean
principal of a high school is a very
tough job and she's very successful
and she created this environment that
we're sitting in
which didn't look like it when i was
here so when i came here
you know i'm gonna make up a little
story here when i came here
i uh i went to the wrong entrance
because when when i went here the school
was completely turned around
and none of it was indoors like it is
today and so
kids have a little bit better than me
you know you i walk 300 miles in the
snow
you know so
but i think it's important for you to
hear that uh darlene i appreciate your
everything you do for the community in
the school district and and the success
of our kids
um so without further ado let me get
into it rancho high school a perfect
reminder that a prosperous future begins
with our children
encouraging their growth and development
and providing them with the tools to
become the next generation
of visionaries i just had a chance to
visit with some of the students
right across the hall here there's four
kids in summer school
so when i went to school you were in
trouble when you went to summer school
right and i had occasion to do that when
i was in school
but these kids do it because it helps
them receive
credit sooner than later gets them
prepared for college
or whatever trade they they choose to
or whatever direction they choose to go
but luckily this morning i went in there
they were making sourdough bread
so rancho is a culinary
um technical school it includes uh
culinary and that's part of their
curriculum
and and they told me all the nuances of
sourdough bread which i didn't know
there was
i thought there was one basic ingredient
with it but they they
informed me i was wrong and so they
walked me through that
but it was it was important for me to
see their enthusiasm
i asked them what it was like to learn
in a pandemic it was encouraging i hear
that to hear the optimism
despite the fact that our governor
denied an entire generation of students
months of critical education
social interaction and activities like
sports music and theater
it was a reminder that our children want
to be optimists they want to learn they
want to succeed
and they want to make the world a better
place
our governor opposes school choice and
has failed to provide a plan to reduce
class size as governor i will block any
team
to force critical race theory on our
public school children
we can teach our children to respect
each other and treat everyone with
dignity
we must bring back a focus on trades so
nevada can attract good paying
manufacturing jobs
and we must do a better job of keeping
our best and brightest
right here in nevada it is easy to
criticize the governor for copying the
world's
the worst policies of some of the most
liberal governors
in the country i think of one right next
to nevada
and there is no denying that steve
sislak is the most partisan governor in
nevada history
but anyone well nearly anyone
could campaign simply on being less
isolated
and less partisan our campaign is
different
it's about ideas it's about returning
some vision
collaboration communication and
leadership to the office
we have a governor and legislature
focused on protecting their own party
guaranteeing single party rule so they
can introduce state income tax
raise your property taxes and advance
public policy
that would make bernie sanders blush
that was actually a funny line
did you get that one see rancho got it
single party rule has led to higher
taxes new regulations and erosion of our
individual freedoms
so let me draw a line in the sand i will
veto any new taxes
that let the legislature sends my way
i think that bears repeating again
i will veto any new taxes
[Applause]
this important part here folks and it
brings us home with law and order
single party rule has led to politicians
focusing on felons rights
prioritizing criminals over victims
weakening penalties for crimes and
handcuffing the police
that isn't sustainable behavior for any
state let alone a state that relies so
heavily
on tourism while portland seattle and
baltimore
gave in to riders looters and vandals we
instituted a zero tolerance policy
for violence let me be clear i will
always stand up for the rights of anyone
to peacefully protest
but if you intend to bring harm to our
people our communities or those visiting
our community
you will face the full force of the law
[Applause]
our short and long-term prosperity is
dependent upon the rule of law
and on a fair and honest judiciary that
respects them protects the constitution
without bias or partisan influence
the rule of law should extend to our
election process
we should all want open and secure
elections where everyone has confidence
in the results
we must undo the reckless partisan
policies out of carson city
and replace them with election law that
is transparent
honest and fair let's demand voter
identification
eliminate ballot harvesting as well as
repeal the new practice of mailing
ballots
to people who do not request them
i support a bipartisan election
integrity commission to oversee our
elections
and guarantee fairness i support a
non-partisan
or bipartisan redistricting commission
so voters have a better chance to let
candidates of their choice
rather than being boxed into districts
designed to benefit a particular
political party
[Applause]
i'm a strong supporter of the second
amendment now that just
isn't rhetoric right mike just
isn't rhetoric i've carried a gun every
day for more than 30 years
in the army as a cop and as your sheriff
i will always support the rights of
law-abiding citizens to responsibly
own and carry guns further i am the only
candidate in the race who made and kept
a promise to eliminate clark county's
gun registry
while political candidates and
committees profit from the dysfunction
of federal government
states are forced to deal with the
problems america is a nation of laws
that must be followed followed with
borders that must be protected but we're
also a nation that should welcome
legal immigration working with a system
that rewards
rewards rule followers but as a zero
tolerance
policy for those who don't
when the aclu and a liberal california
judge
liesel for those who don't know that's
my attorney sitting there
she's the one that protects my back
the aclu and a liberal california judge
denied us the opportunity to use federal
database to determine the true identity
of criminals
we adjusted and dedicated more internal
resources
dedicated more internal resources to
identify
to identifying and deporting violent
criminals
i need that to sink in a little bit
there's been a lot of rhetoric out there
that i have created a sanctuary of
jurisdiction
and that is absolutely not true what we
did is adjust
moved resources and addressed the
problem
to move forward versus backing up and
say we raised our hands and gave up
it's important for people to realize
that
america cannot have a dignified and
respectful immigration policy without
defending our borders
protecting our citizens and removing
those who wish to do our nation
and our people harm one of the things
that has made nevada great
is our wide variety diversity
and leaders who focus on creating
opportunity for all nevadans
nevadans believe that if you work hard
and play by the rules that you can
create your own american dream
as i but the current governor chooses
the winners and losers
this isn't right and it's time to take
it back our state for all nevadans
as sheriff i relied upon a multicultural
advisory committee to work through
community and law enforcement challenges
to help us better understand the sources
of conflict
and diffuse difficult situations
creating a committee isn't unique in
politics
but listening to its members is
at metro everyone has a seat at the
table but in carson city that just
isn't the case that ends the day i'm
sworn in
the metro multicultural advisory
committee
in mac has written or changed policies
addressing derogatory social media
our gang database recruiting and
diversity training
those are just a few of their
accomplishments the important piece is
we didn't refuse to listen
we collaborated for solutions
i will set a clear vision as governor
and my administration will advance
towards
specific goals consistent with that
vision
relying on our leadership experience and
commitment
of a diverse group of nevadans
interesting piece i received recently
somebody close to
the current administration is our
governor has failed to meet with her
his leaders and i think it's important
piece to provide leadership and vision
and direction
that that has to occur that simple task
is really troublesome to me
and it's one of the biggest failures
associated with leadership
so it bothers me to know in and i can
see the direction we're going as a
result of that
i think it's important for you know i
grew up here went to school here and
after serving in the army
came back to back here to serve and
protect nevadans
i've been a proud to stand up for the
victims of crime and stand up for those
who wish to do us harm
i am a proud veteran a former beat cop
and the chief executive of an agency
that prides itself on being tough
and accountable sink that in tough and
accountable
i will stand by my record as your
sheriff for the last seven and a half
years
in my last 33 years on the police
department
on how our police department has
performed protected the community
and i believe a fantastic job
this is an important piece folks i have
been elected twice as a conservative
in our state's bluest county
i have never compromised our principles
to get elected and won't do so now
today i'm standing here to announce my
candidacy for governor
because if we don't put an end to the
single party rule
eroding our state of the values laws and
opportunities to make nevada great
we won't have a lot left to fight for
[Applause]
for those who don't know i'm sheriff joe
lombardo
i'm running for governor and i hope you
will join me in taking back
our state